bring healing and restoration to demar's  body right now and with heads bowed and  eyes closed fans and members of the  Buffalo Bills Community gathered outside  Highmark Stadium to pray for Demar  Hamlin we all feel and hurt when one of  us gets hurt a player comes to Buffalo  they're not just playing  compared across the Sports World I just  wanted to send my condolences to Mr  Hamlin or the Buffalo Bills the NFL has  United around Hamlin too all 32 teams  posted this on Twitter pray for Demar  the bills Rivals the New England  Patriots paid tribute to lighting up  their Stadium Jumbotron to an empty  stadium in the bills blue and red colors  and with this message Patriot Nation  stands with Demar Hamlin